we tend to think of
science and ideology as completely
separate when i think the reality is
there is there not
if you look at why the mayans in the 7th
and 8th century a.d had the world's most
accurate calendar
accurate to within 17 seconds per year
that was all part of a ritual practice
to celebrate
the rise of kukulkan the rise of the of
venus with what's called the heliacal
rise rising namely the rising of venus
before the
rising of the sun in which which
at which moment venus is destroyed by
the light of the sun
well
they developed this elaborate
calendrical astronomy which required
detailed observation detailed
chronicling of movement of the heavens
in particular the planets
for the purpose of celebrating
this cycle of renewal that they thought
was sacred and and uh holy and and
magical
so where's the ideology where's the
science there's the the sort of
instrumentation the calendrics the
measure the measurement all in the
service
of this
magical moment
and i think that's true of a lot of
science i had a friend years ago who was
mennonite and wanted to study solar
cells and to improve silicon chips to
make more efficient solar energy
there was no money for that
when ronald reagan took office
the budgets for solar and alternative
energy were essentially zeroed out and
reagan takes off the
solar panels off of the roof of the
white house
so
my friend end up ends up working on
hardening
silicon chips against nuclear war so he
becomes part of the nuclear war
protection defense apparatus even though
he wanted to work on alternative energy
doing very similar work with silicon
chips but in a different framework and
so
the practice of science often gets
pushed into and is is woven into
ideological practices and sort of in the
same way that you get beautiful
um medieval cathedrals built
uh in service of of catholicism
well what's in the mind of an individual
scientist so this this process of
ideology polluting science or is it
science empowering ideology so
almost like uh if you can zoom in and
zoom out
effortlessly into the individual mind of
a scientist then back to the whole
scientific community like do scientists
think about
nuclear war
about the atrocities committed by the
nazis as they're helping on the minute
details of the scientific process i
think sometimes they do and sometimes
they don't right you think of the
chemists
working to develop the
cyanide that will be used to kill
jews at
in a concentration camp what are they
thinking
you can imagine a whole range of
thoughts maybe
they don't know what they're doing
maybe they do maybe they know a little
bit but not a lot maybe they don't want
to know
maybe they have ways of of lying to
themselves
maybe they are the one person who agreed
to do it in
99
refused
so
you know it's
hard if not impossible to know what's in
the soul of anyone
but when you have enormous power
directing the motion
and the currents or the ocean
it's not hard
to find people willing to fill that in
especially if they're narrow technocrats
you know if they're just doing their job
if they're just building the widget
and i think a lot of
scientific training is in widget widget
building and that leads to the
possibility that they can become easily
instrumentalized
in a particular
uh in a particular action which is maybe
horrific or or glorious
the other thing to keep in mind is that
sciences as we say what scientists do
and
that can include a lot of things that
can exclude a lot of things
the word science itself is interesting
because it's cognate it actually comes
originally from the proto-indo-european
uh
skein meaning to cut
or divide
and so it's cognate with
scissors
schism
skin skin is that which divides you from
the world [ __ ] or scat is that which has
been divided from you
uh into the world
and so there's this cognate uh between
science and [ __ ] or science and cutting
with the whole idea being that you're
dividing into parts classifying it's the
taxonomic impulse
and
to know is to know where something
belongs to divide it into its parts and
put it in its proper place and that
taxonomic impulse can be very static
it's actually one of the things that
darwin had to overcome in recognizing
evolution that the taxonomies are in
motion
but it also can lead to a kind of myopia
that my job is done when i've classified
something
is is is this bird an x a y or a z
and
that again can be
it can be ideological or it cannot be
but
scientists are humans humans and they're
fitting in
with a world with a world practice
and that's that's that's limiting it's
kind of inevitable it's unavoidable it's
hard to be if not impossible
out of the world
that we're that we're walking in
you